what mistakes do writers make when
writing characters
i think the mistakes that writers make
when writing characters is that
everybody kind of sounds like themselves
or
uh
just sounds
um
yeah too flat or that they put too much
of the characterization into the
description
um and that's ultimately you know just a
tiny tiny sliver of it
um you know that comes so much from the
dialogue and how they interact with
people and what they say in response to
a line
you know if somebody says
you know how is your day and then they
completely take it off topic
or you know they they fire back at them
or you know it's it's it's the way in
which these interactions happen
um and i think ultimately film is about
representing vitality and representing
life
and
so characters too should be
you know as engaging as possible and as
fired up as possible and i think um uh
sometimes
sometimes it's maybe playing it a little
bit too safe um with with certain
characters and and having the freedom to
you know really really go out there and
really really be bold
are there certain screenwriters who you
love their dialogue
whether it's understated or or even like
an aaron sorkin where it's so there's
such a performance from each line it's
great to listen to certainly aaron
sorkin is that i mean when anybody talks
about dialogue it's hard to hard to not
just zero in on him um and what's
phenomenal about him is how
the exposition can roll on and on and on
but you're still there right and he also
you know is so great at non-sequiturs
and then sort of bringing it back home
about why this particular story was
important or why this was said
and the nuance to language that he
brings with with different characters of
why they say certain things and how it's
crafted
um is is really i think something to to
be admired and studied
what questions should a writer be asking
themselves about their characters while
they're writing it i think the one chief
question writers should be asking
themselves
constantly is is this true to life
is this
um
somebody i know
is this what is the is this reality and
then if you know if there is another
question it's is this somebody i would
want to spend time with for an hour and
a half in a theater you know it's um
uh
and it could also be you know there's so
many ways to answer that it could be
like well
they're they're kind of you know a
dumpster fire but
that could be entertaining you know like
um
but
but then also weaving that it you always
have to for me you always have to look
at it in the in sort of the gestalt of
how does it how does it interact with
these other parts so
uh you obviously don't want to have
somebody who's a complete villain
uh you know as you're trying to
um
trying to get audiences to empathize or
you know tell a story about about
somebody who's a hero right those things
just won't match so it's also what's the
what's the
uh intention with this character and
then is it somebody you would want to
spend time with and are they a real
person that that you could point to in
the world
right he's a
young adult
she she was sort of a dumpster fire for
a while in the movie and
fascinating journey to be on that and
same leaving las vegas
so yeah there's there's some that are
fascinating to watch and yeah there's
others that are painful to watch and
it's like this is maybe a little too
much yeah
i mean i think the reason we're drawn to
those types of characters is like often
you know
the light is shining brightest before it
goes out
and um and those are people really on
the brink who are struggling to to
you know struggling with their their own
inner demons and so
their behavior is is just bombastic
and um
and
yeah it's it's certainly certainly
something to watch
how do you find out what a character
wants i think in looking what a
character wants it's a really tricky
question and as a director i always
will do that with the actors because we
need to be in alignment
and ultimately i need them to be more
connected to that than ultimately me
because that's what is a good
performance
and
and i think that comes with you know
writing down the facts writing down the
facts of the script
and sometimes the character might
directly you know tell you um or the
director
or the the actor might um
might lie might say you know i want this
and you can say well look at these other
facts right he may say that he wants a
good job but he's showing up every day
drunk right and so what is it that he
does really
want and and that is i think is finding
the spine and and and asking those
questions and and kind of referencing
them back to the facts in the script
and you said that dialogue you often let
actors bring their own like it doesn't
have to be on the nose in terms of what
the script is and you feel that that
that helps in terms of the believability
the chemistry yeah i'm i'm always
hiring actors who
[Music]
are bringing themselves um doesn't mean
they can't you know play another
character but that uh that they're
bringing their own good ideas
and we will workshop things and then
we'll go back and rewrite the script
based off of what they've said or we'll
do a rehearsal or we'll do an improv
and something will come out that is
brilliant that's going in and i'll you
know add it into the script it really
it really evolves and and
and that too
is so
helpful for actors when they're doing
the scenes because they they really have
a sense in which everything is alive
everything is changing and everything uh
there's things at stake and so they need
to be super engaged um
they need to be listening to one another
uh and also that you know if they get a
wild hair they're free to express it and
um and it's gonna be welcome
what techniques do you use to strengthen
your characters
the techniques
i use to strengthen characters are again
pointing to
uh the real world and um and again doing
that with
with the actors
um but ultimately
in a script i can only do so much it
it's only real when it's on screen
and
and i
really encourage the actors to uh
to ask those questions and to have those
conversations and ultimately it's it's
for for me i i know there's different
things that are more playable and that
will work in engaging a scene and making
it feel more lively or hitting specific
plot points or you know having the
pacing uh be a certain way
um and so all sort of
yeah direct and and
you know mold things here and there but
the it's the actor's job to
really
uh
build that depth and and really make it
make it playable and and and to connect
it and and find
uh
find a way to bring it to life on on
screen um and you know that i think is
is solid script analysis and and we
always spend a lot of time doing that
and it's really one of my favorite parts
of the process and it's so collaborative
and it's um
it yeah it's always a lot of fun i i
really do love working with actors what
character in a film that you've watched
just really hits home for you that just
it's so real that you're convinced that
that person
lives somewhere and
some walk up in new york city or
something
i think
certainly making characters that are
more complex makes everything a lot more
playable and and so
that too i'm in more in writing um i'm
really an advocate for of of finding
where
uh
they just completely are you know
irrational or
uh
yeah where we're where
on paper you're like that doesn't really
make sense but then there's that person
right
um
that just brings the complexity i mean
jj opens so much so often it's like you
know good narrative structure is about
having a question right and um and
uh
whether it's a mystery or whether it's
it's like that's what draws an audience
in and so i think if you have more
complex characters
that um
it draws people in again it's like what
what does make this person tick um
and
yeah and and uh
certainly certainly for me it also has
been sort of the most engaging
characters i've seen on screen
what was it about jonah hill's character
in wolf of wall street that really
struck you
i mean so many of the characters in in
wolf of wall street um
whether it was matthew mcconaughey or
leo dicaprio i mean i think it was
everybody's obsession with
uh
wealth for wealth's sake
and i thought scorsese handled it so
well you know that no character in that
ever
gets off easy
even goes he even goes to such depths to
show well you know this
um
this hooker and this traitor you know
went off and got married but it didn't
end well like he he literally went and
showed that it did not end well as just
a moral story like that this world does
not lead to bliss right that this leads
to despair leads to suicide
and um
that was fascinating watching all of
those characters explore that you know
where that emanated from
uh
how it was this sort of constantly
perpetuating cycle
and certainly the glitz around it that
made it feel worthwhile